the Joe Rogan experience ah
you know what I hate most in anything
street fights is when the dudes heads
bounce off the concrete brutal brutal
there's one this is Puerto Rican dude
and this other guy and the guy doesn't
know how to fight in the Puerto Rican
dude does and you can see they're
standing in front of each other yeah he
just crack and the guy goes and you see
him like sideways his head bounces up
and his girlfriend goes get in the car
puppy he jumps in the car it takes off
oh my god I think it's a movie and then
the real life kicks in some well some
people are they're just fronting and
they think right gonna get away with it
and then the other guy is actually a
boxer right and that was the case here
that guy he threw an educated punch like
he knew what he was doing and he caught
that guy right in the jaw and he went
out his head and the bounce there's a
[ __ ] this thing that kills it's like
dude I grew up in Louisiana and these
like corn-fed white guys with polo
shirts and Doc Martens and short short
blue shorts with the woven belt they
would get these brawls these big white
[ __ ] and they would just like
kick him in the face when they're down
like a sucker he just be outside the bar
like I just watch the guy get his jaw
broken none on a Friday night that you
know 1:00 in the morning
and he just go back in the bar I mean it
was horrific horrific they slamming
people in the cars and need them in the
face how many people have died and
barfle I know I know
terrible ya know the jaw gets wire you
see the guy the next week he's got that
neck brace you know brutal ya follow for
what cuz somebody bumped in here
they spilled your beer well just people
looking for fights and then they get a
little bit of booze in them and you know
they're mad because their girlfriends
[ __ ] some new guy [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
have that in me I don't have that anger
like isolations I'm not braggin I like
to booze it up I like to smash some gash
and have a good time and do some shrooms
and you know eat a lady out but I can't
imagine wanting to kick a guy in the
face while he's on the ground
no um is that not good that's a rage
maybe he was beaten or he's deep deeply
closeted or something's going on there
well it's like
some men grow up getting their asses
kicked I guess grow up getting abused
it's one of the one of the things that I
would notice in high school
the kids that would want to fight all
the time they were getting abused at
home ah there's a lot of that right now
and they don't have as much guilt about
it they'll just smash your face exactly
I would be like oh shut up someone's
been doing that to them whether it's
their older brother or right where
they're getting bullied and so they
bully people back you know that old
expression hurt people hurt people
yeah yeah and that's you know when
people like to herb you that was the
thing that I hated the most about
fighting was when I would knock someone
out yes it would weird me out I get it
man I would like to try to celebrate oh
just try out try to like and then after
a while I started not celebrating I
would just walk away yeah like that's
actually probably better move anyway it
looks cooler cuz I would just smash
somebody I would kick them and then they
would go down like that dudes not good
enough I'm just gonna walk away like
this always happens kind of always
happened yeah like getting MMA when they
do knock the guy down and they walk away
they don't even hammer fisting well it's
a thing it's like when guys do do that
they're letting you know like I know
rice is this is the end yeah yeah I
don't have to follow this up right
because there's a feeling that you get
when you hit someone you see their eyes
roll back like you know no but some guys
are so savage they don't give a [ __ ]
[Applause]